hi there Steve Kaufman here I'm back in
Palm Springs sitting in my little room
here today I'm gonna talk about tests
and quizzes and drills and those kinds
of things my view on them but just
looking at this sort of bleak background
here I think I should get myself some
kind of a background maybe a sheet of
something that has a see some scenery or
link maybe I don't know anyway back in
Palm Springs and of course I come down
here because my work doesn't like it
when it rains all the time in Vancouver
we had a week of snow even which is a
bit uncommon but here the weather isn't
all that great but still it's 20 22
degrees centigrade whereas at home now
it's like 8 or 6 and raining and before
we left it was like zero or two minus
and snowing and so here you can get a
walk I've already done on my bicycle
tool around and studying my Arabic and
farsi um tests so the reason I want to
talk about this is that there was a
follow different people on Twitter and
there's a professor I think it's
Willingham who is an expert on education
whom I very much respect and I enjoy
whatever he tweets and he said that most
students won't do the optional questions
after whatever subject they're studying
even though he says retrieval is so
important for improving our learning in
our memory and retrieval means like
answering questions about what you have
just read so I was thinking about this
as it relates to language learning he of
course wasn't talking about language
learning he was talking about some other
you know it could be chemistry or
history or anything else where if you
answer questions you're forced to jog
your memory and and look for meaning and
that this helps you retain things and
I'm thinking now does this apply to
language learning of course my own
prejudice is that I never do these tests
drills questions I hate them if they
have them in a book that I buy like
inevitably writers of textbooks feel
that they have to make
these drills and questions and I never
do them at at the you know what I might
do is I might look up the answers at the
back of the book because it'll tend to
have these patterns so if they were
testing you for you know certain verb
forms or the genitive for the whatever
it might be then you'll see 10 or 15
examples there that and so I like
exposure I like repeated exposure to
patterns to forms and stuff like that
and I resist doing these tests I hate
them in fact I won't do them and getting
back to professor Willingham I guess a
lot of students won't do them either but
uh what I'd like to know and I want to
get your response and imbues on this is
you know does it really help us retrieve
like if you're learning science or
history then yes you want to try to
retrieve these facts but when we're
learning a language if the main thing in
language learning is your enjoyment and
the time you spend with the language and
taking it in and then even talking to
people but but talking about things of
interest significant things things that
that have meaning and of course when you
are speaking then you are trying to
retrieve the language even when you are
reading new material say I'm reading the
transcript as I now have transcripts of
podcasts in Arabic or Persian then as I
see my screen on link I have blue words
that are new so there I'm not retrieving
anything getting a meaning but yellow
words are words that I have saved before
that I now no longer remember so I go
there but I don't scratch my head trying
to remember what they mean I don't you
know spend a lot of time thinking about
what what's the meaning I just go and
get it right away that's how we designed
the many stories as well we have
questions after each mini story and the
mini story has of course Part A and Part
B so two different points of view two
different times maybe different person
and then we have questions where we
provide the answer we say Steve is
making a video is Steve watching
television no Steve is making a video so
the answer is given to you that the
statement is given the question is asked
and then
the answers provided and so that the
same vocabulary more or less is provided
three times quite quickly and I find
that that is more effective and then
then questions so when I'm listening to
this while doing the dishes driving my
car I'm not scratching my head trying to
think we know what was the doing I just
hear it and so it's just washing over me
and gradually these patterns are
becoming a part of me and I saw a very
interesting video by a manfred Spitzer
because I had a heaven exchange with
someone in German and pretty soon you'll
see that here I spoke to Katya who has a
channel for German and so to prepare for
that I thought geez I never speak German
I should maybe get into my German a
little bit so I started googling for
articles on language learning in German
and up pops Manfred Spitzer and then
there's reference to a video of his so I
watched the video and he makes the point
that that we have trouble our brains and
he's a neuroscientist who has I've had a
lot of very good things to say I read
his book down on us get him you know
learning at the brain and the brain he
points out the brain always learns we
don't know what the brain is learning
though the brain learns on its own time
its own schedule if the teacher might
teach the subjunctive the brain might
decide to learn the subjunctive six
months later if we don't know what the
brain is learning but the brain looks to
looks for relevance so if the brain has
trouble with with detail individual
detail and that's why we so quickly
forget if we meet someone at a party and
they're introduced to us we forget the
name right away if I look something up
in the dictionary I forget it right away
because the brain hasn't yet been
convinced that this is something that
long-term is important to the brain the
brain likes to create rules patterns
that help us navigate life so that
things that come come at us see you
three four five six seven times the
brain says okay this is important this
I'm gonna
I'm gonna make sense of this and so just
a little individual date all by itself
it is not considered meaningful to the
brain and that's why at least in
language learning sort of flooding your
brain with lots of content where similar
words and patterns show up in different
contexts the brain says AHA this is
important here I got to figure out what
the pattern is and so the I thought that
was a very interesting video again if
you google manfred Spitzer and trying to
remember the name of the veena whole
like repeating I think what was the name
of that particular video manfred spitzer
SP IT said ER manfred spitzer poof so
given that that's how the brain learns
are we better off to spend a lot of time
scratching our heads
aside from the fact that it's annoying
it's annoying to be questioned about
something if the objective is to enjoy
the content I find it not enjoyable to
be asked questions about what I've just
read even worse is in literature class
when they ask you to identify symbolism
and all kinds of strange stuff and I I
never never just totally destroys the
pleasure of of reading and listening to
things so so the question is this you
know a supposedly retrieval strengthens
your ability to remember things say in
general as a learning principle
according to a neuroscientists or some
group of them on the other hand how does
it affect our enjoyment of the process
is it really that meaningful to us are
we better off - just like I often say
even in something like history if you
read two or three books on the same
subject and you're getting different
perspectives so you're rediscovering
things that you already know and that's
kind of confirming them and you're kind
of grabbing it and learning it better
whereas questioning questioning you on
something you've just read is it's
perhaps a form of block learning again
trying to nail down details in that
rather than letting the brain gradually
form an understanding of I'll just let
that ring so that's the question I would
like your opinion
r10
drills all this other stuff useful or
not and bear in mind that in my language
learning I did tests in French at school
couldn't speak it when I left the
testing environment I became better
because I I read I read newspapers
watched Nouvelle Vague movies and stuff
like that now in Chinese I had tests but
I did better than the other students we
all had the same number of tests I did
better than they did because I read more
and I listened more and once I've
finished with Chinese for all the other
languages I've never done drills never
done tests I avoid them totally so I'd
like your views on this drills tests
quizzes asking you to retrieve
information does it really help you
learn or are you better off to spend
that time exposing yourself to more of
the language in meaningful context and
allowing the brain to gradually sort
things up now you know where I stand on
it so but I'd be interested in your use
thank you for listening bye for now